a writer who smokes the right things I
mean you know you from be in a room and
you know JFK's shopping party but he
doesn't know how to tell the story it
isn't gonna be compelling it was a real
mouthy combative kid that just sort of
didn't really acknowledge any Authority
probably demonstrations over you know
right I'd send your things in my diary
and have the misfortune to have it read
by the headteacher and stuff like that a
great success story was that we arrived
it just at the time that Lady Diana
Spencer became one of the biggest
stories of the social stories of the
20th century all of these great writers
were writing for Tyler and yet it was
also very fun content with a lot of
attitude when I took it over it had
250,000 sales everybody thought it was a
bit of a joke but we very quickly as it
a remade Vanity Fair and we took it to
1.1 million from the last big growth
that we had as the Demi Moore pregnant
cover and that just took us over the top
when I first went over there to be the
editor I looked around this table it was
all men all of them looking at me
glaring at me
Shifa the cartoonists are actually the
most hostile of them all The Daily Beast
was a more lovely frisky invention that
had fantastic young talent and a huge
spark with one new side of the year two
years running we grew exponentially you
know to 16 million uniques
our hope was that that we would
reanimate the more about in Newsweek but
nothing could actually reanimate news
meat because it was a wholly different
full of problems when did you realize
that it wasn't going to work and about
the first week trying to reanimate a
weekly magazine at a time when the whole
marketing with magazines is collapsed it
was really a bit too quixotic even for
me I think it's a diffusion kind of
course and lackluster environment where
operating and now compared to some
periods celebrity culture has got more
and more sort of low in its expectations
and it's much more in ephemeral so
someone's a star for five minutes
because of a YouTube hit and that's it
but pretend to be optimistic about the
constant changing of everything so I
think that things will emerge from this
murky sort of slime slump Armin in which
we learn